Shido is unique revolutionary into
wildly imaginative everything he ended
up getting built out of the fact that
civilization is vanished and the fact
that everybody's wanting to build a
world out you need that time to think
and to do research or to feel real and
grounded when building this world we put
together an amazing team we consulted
the blind community about how the
building would be constructed by someone
who is blind but it looked like what it
would feel like in the kind of people
and how they live and how they are
together
[Music]
wanting to make sure that the show felt
like it took place in North America and
so we chose British Columbia it's very
easy for it to feel like other things
you may have seen we started to scour
the land trying to make sure that we
found places that felt untouched the
choice to build sets and distant
locations made things challenging a lot
of the thought went into creating
something that was visual even though
our characters are unable to see it a
lot of the costumes were constructed in
terms of what these people would have
built the Scenic's that set decorator
crop masters were amazing details
unbelievable a really tactile and scent
orientated world with the Queen she has
these metal rings that we've put bells
in and so when she commands the kingdom
she does this thing with her hands so
everybody knows her sound and everybody
knows then to bow down to her
we use scarification because it's
something that people could feel it
could be a way of identifying their
hierarchy so many things were born out
of this idea of blindness in different
ways people can navigate are they using
echolocation are they using sound or
they using road as the blindness
consultant on the show see a trained
actors how we move through the world
anytime you take away in a sense and
focus on your other senses you'll pick
up information in a different way
teach what is their intention I feel
savage intent in here we have to
translate all of the things that are
human behavior into up deeper listening
it's a big ambitious unique and very
different show the action looks like
nothing you see the visuals ending the
Russian design everything's that her own
character it was a challenge and I can't
tell you how hard they worked on
anything
the longer the journey the more profound
its challenges the more it changes all
who endure it your family we are one and
we fight is one
you
you